vous le savez le président de la
république à échanger et suite à ce
qu'il est intervenu à la route à ce
week-end et vous rappeliez le caractère
épouvantable et abominable des images
que nous avons vues il n'a changé que le
présentera cette nuit ils ont convenu de
donner instruction à leurs équipes
respectives de pouvoir approfondir les
échanges dans les prochains jours et ce
soir se réunit à 21h heure de paris une
importante réunion du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui permettra
l'espérons de prendre des décisions la
ligne rouge il a marqué dès le mois de
février et il a rappelé que si
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques étaient
avérées bien cela appellerait une
riposte vous avez vous dis toujours si
donc il ya une réunion du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui se tient
ce soir à 21h heure de paris ne s'en
seront plus affûtés
qu'est-ce que vous avez des preuves
aujourd'hui effectivement emmanuel
macron il a toujours dit nous
n'interviendrons que si nous avons des
preuves qu'il ya une utilisation d'armes
chimiques est ce qu'aujourd'hui on est
en mesure d'apporter des aides apportées
il faut que tous les moyens qu'ils
puissent être mises en oeuvre pour
déterminer si oui ou non ils à usage
d'armes chimiques puissent être mises à
la disposition des enquêteurs
à ce stade les informations dont nous
sommes en notre possession confirme a
priori l'utilisation d'armes chimiques
adacore donc on s'oriente donc vers
l'utilisation de la force à nouveau
réplique à nouveau cité cette ligne
rouge s'avérait être franchie il y
aurait une riposte comme le président de
la république s'y est engagé à maintes
reprise
le trump l'avait déjà fait une fois de
bombarder le régime syrien après un
incident similaire est ce que c'est une
bonne stratégie finalement les effets
avait été un incident c'est la violation
caractérisée du droit international et
notamment de l'interdiction
d'utilisation d'armes chimiques et en
particulier sur des populations civiles
des images qu'on a vu hier soir
en atteste village contre des civils des
femmes des enfants jeunes adolescents et
donc il ya déjà eu des frappes vous le
rappeliez présentera meute avait frappé
un dernière si cela devait s'avérer à
nouveau être le cas il faudrait frapper
est-ce que c'est cela qui permet de
sortir du conflit terrible que connaît
la syrie depuis maintenant sept années
sans doute pas mais si cela permet de
mettre à mal des installations qui
permettent de produire des arts
chimiques ou de lait militarisé ou de
les utiliser bien c'est une somme toute
bonne décision mais ce qu'israël a
proposé à la france